The first thing I would say is that if
you're dealing with someone who's
depressed and they're really depressed,
you should try giving him
antidepressants because if they die,
you can't help them.
Okay,
so if you're suffering,
you are obligated in a sense to hold
onto whatever roped someone throws you,
and one of the things I do with my
clients all the time,
especially if they're really in trouble,
is to tell them,
look,
I don't know exactly what's going to
help you,
but don't arbitrarily throw out any
possibilities because you might not have
that luxury and antidepressants help a
lot of people and there are technical
reasons why that's the case.
So that's a simple answer.
It's not relevant to what I already
described except that if you're offered
a gift by your society and it works,
try it.
I don't care what your presuppositions
are.
Apart from that,
lots of lots of time,
lots of the time you see people who are
suffering with depression,
for example.
There's a multitude of reasons,
but I'll take one common reason,
um,
you could think about it as associated
with the story of Peter Pan.
Peter Pan is someone who won't grow up
right now.
The problem with Peter Pan is he gets to
be king,
but it's King of Neverland.
Neverland doesn't exist,
so being king of nothing isn't that
helpful?
Well,
one of the things that you often see
with people who suffer from depression
and and and not making a blanket
statement about the cause of depression
because there's lots of them,
is that people who don't have enough
order in their life tend to get
overwhelmed.
So for example,
if someone comes into me and see to see
me and they say they're depressed,
I always asked him a very standard set
of questions.
Do you have a job?
If you don't have a job,
you're really in trouble in our society.
First of all,
you,
your biological rhythms stand to go off
the rails right away because there's no
reason to go to bed at any particular
time and there's no reason to get up.
And for many people,
if they don't get up at the same time,
they follow up the functioning of their
circadian rhythms and that's enough to
make them depressed right off the bat.
Especially if they start napping during
the afternoon,
they also don't have a purpose.
People aren't good without a purpose,
and this isn't.
This isn't hypothesizing.
We absolutely understand the circuitry
that underlies positive emotion.
We know how it works.
Almost all the positive emotion that any
of you are likely to experience in your
life will not be a consequence of
attaining things.
It will be a consequence of seeing that
things are working as you proceed
towards a goal you value,
that's completely different and you need
to know this because people are often
stunned.
For example,
they finished their phd thesis and their
presupposition is that they're going to
be elated for a month and often instead
they're actually depressed and they
think,
what?
Hell I'd been working on this for seven
years and I handed it in and what do I
do now?
And that's what depresses them,
right?
It's the,
what do I do now?
Well,
they're are fine.
If they enjoyed it,
pursuing the thing,
as long as it was working out,
they get a lot of enthusiasm and
excitement over that because that's how
our nervous systems work.
Most of your positive emotion is goal
pursuit.
Emotion.
If take drugs like cocaine or
amphetamine,
the reason they're enjoyable is because
they turn on the systems that help you
pursue goals.
That's why people like them.
So if you don't have a job,
you got no structure,
that's not good.
Plus you tend not to have a point.
So you're overwhelmed by chaotic lack of
structure and you don't have any
positive emotion.
Well,
do you have any friends?
So sometimes you see people who are
depressed,
they have no job,
they have no friends,
they have no intimate relationship,
they have an additional health problem
and they have a drug and alcohol
problem.
My experience has been,
if you have three of those problems,
it's almost impossible to help you.
You're so deeply mired in chaos that you
can't get out because you make progress
on one front and one of your other
problems pulls you down.
So one of the things I tell people who
are depressed is like,
don't sacrifice your stability.
Get a job.
Even if it's not the job you exactly
want,
get a damn job.
You need a job.
Find some friends,
get out in the dating circuit,
see if you can establish an intimate
relationship,
put together some of the foundation
litems that,
that are like pillars that you're life
rests on.
Well,
that's the practical thing to do.
So that's one example with regards to
depression.
Well,
the thing is you don't just launch it on
them,
you know,
you got to negotiate with the person and
you also got to teach them to negotiate
with themselves.
And this is something that's very useful
to know,
you know,
um,
you can tyrannized yourself into doing
things,
but I wouldn't recommend it.
What I would recommend instead is that
you ask yourself what you're willing to
do.
It's a really effective technique.
It's like a meditative techniques.
So for example,
you can get up in the morning,
you can take,
well,
you know,
I'd like to have a good day to day.
So I'd like to go to bed tonight without
feeling guilty because I didn't do some
things I said I was going to do and I,
you know,
I'd like to have kind of an interesting
day.
So you've got to fulfill my
responsibilities.
And I want to,
you know,
enjoy the day.
Then you can ask yourself,
well,
okay,
what would I have to do in order for
that to happen that I would do?
And the probability if you practice this
for three or four days is your brain
will just tell you.
They'll say,
well,
you know,
there's that piece of homework that you
haven't done for like three weeks.
You should knock that sucker off because
it will only take you 10 minutes and
you've been avoiding it and torturing
yourself to death for like 72 hours
straight.
And if you do that,
here's a little interesting thing you
can do.
And you know,
maybe this is a little obligations you
should clean up.
And so what,
what you do in a situation like that as
you teach the person to negotiate with
themselves say,
well let's figure out what your aims
are.
You going to have some ames,
whatever they are.
And they might say,
well,
I'm so depressed I don't have any aims.
And then I say,
well,
pick the least objectionable of the Ames
and act it out for awhile and see what
happens.
Because sometimes your emotional,
your emotional systems are so followed
up that you have to pretend you have to
act the thing out before you can start
to believe it.
I mean,
people always assume they have to
believe in Vanap,
but,
but that's sometimes that's true in lots
of times.
It isn't.
So the trick,
if you're doing therapeutic work with
somebody and you're helping them
establish a structure,
is to find out what they'll do.
Now,
if they want to get better,
which is not a given because there are
often payoffs for not getting better
other.
That's basically the payoffs of being a
martyr or maybe the payoffs of doing
what you're entirely pathological family
members want you to do because they
actually want you to fail.
Assuming you want to get better,
there's usually something you can figure
out that would constitute a step toward
some sort of concrete goal.
And my presumption,
it's a behavior of presumptions
fundamentally is that small accruing
gains that repeat unbelievably powerful.
So you know,
this is another thing to know about in
your own life.
It's something I learned in part from
reading the writings of Aleksandr
Solzhenitsyn.
He was a great Russian philosopher and
novelist,
you know,
he said you can look at your life and
you can see what isn't right about it.
We know you have to do is look,
and then you can start to fix that.
And the way you fix it is by noticing
what you could in fact fix,
you know,
people are often trying to fix things
they can fix,
which I would not recommend because if
you try to fix something you can't text,
you'll just ruin it.
Like you can find all sorts of
undergraduates who are perfectly willing
to restructure the,
uh,
you know,
the international economic system who
cannot keep the room clean and there's
actually a gap there,
you know,
which,
and it's surprising that people don't
actually notice.
So I would say if you pay attention,
you can see things that you could fix.
They yell at you,
they really do.
We even know how that happens.
Let me,
let me give you an example because rooms
are full of stories and the stories have
have effects on you.
So here's a classic experiment.
So you take two groups of
undergraduates,
you bring them into your lab and you
give one group on a multiple choice test
that has a bunch of words in it that are
associated with being old and you give
the other group the same multiple choice
test except the words are associated
with being young.
This is independent of the content of
the test.
It's just descriptions and then you
time.
The undergraduate says they walked back
to the elevators,
the ones who read,
the ones who completed the multiple
choice tests that had more words
associated with aging,
walk slower back to the elevators and
they don't know that and they don't know
they're doing it and that that study has
been replicated in various forms.
Many,
many times.
You're unbelievably sensitive to the
story that your environment is telling
you because your environment is not made
out of objects.
That's just wrong.
Your environment is basically made out
of something like tools and obstacles.
You're a tool using creature.
You a tool perceiving creature,
the things you like.
If I take you out of this room and I
said,
well,
what was in the room?
You're not going to say,
uh,
you know,
random patterns in the carpet because
they're,
they're real or just as good an object.
Is there anything else?
You're going to say chairs because you
can sit on them and you're going to say
handrails because you can hold them.
You can say stairs because you can walk
down them.
That's what you see and that's what you
interact with and if you'll pay
attention to your environment,
which is you,
by the way,
extended all of your experiences,
you,
it will tell you all the time what you
should do.
All you have to do is do it,
but then you have to decide if you want
to do it.
One of the things I've noticed about
people because I've wondered once I
started studying this mythological
stories and I got this idea about the,
the fact that life can be meaningful
enough to justify it suffering.
I thought,
God,
that's such a good idea because it's not
optimistic.
Exactly.
You know,
some people will tell you what,
you can be happy.
It's like those people are idiots.
I'm telling you,
they're idiots.
There's going to be things that come
along that flat new so hard you won't
believe it and you're not happy then,
and so if life is to be happy while in
those situations,
what are you doing?
Why even live,
but that isn't?
Life isn't to be happy.
If you're happy,
you're bloody fortunate and you should
enjoy it.
You should because it's the grace of
God,
so to speak.
With regards to meaning,
I thought,
well,
people know when they're doing something
meaningful,
they can tell,
so why the hell don't they do meaningful
things all the time?
It seems obvious you could do it.
I mean it's hard,
you know,
because other people want you to do
other things and it's a struggle,
but everything's a struggle and then I
thought,
well,
oh,
I get it.
I see why it took me about 10 years to
figure this out.
People have a choice.
Choice number one,
nothing you do means anything.
Well,
that's kind of a drag,
right?
Meaninglessness of life and all that
existential angst,
you know,
that's kind of a pain,
but the upside of nothing that you do is
meaningful is you don't have to do
anything.
You've got no responsibility.
No,
you have to suffer because things are
meaningless,
but that's a small price to pay for
being able to be completely useless.
The alternative,
the alternative is everything you do
matters.
Really,
if you make a mistake,
it's a real mistake.
If you'd be traced someone,
you tilt the world a little more sharply
towards evil rather than good.
It matters what you do well.
If you buy that,
then you can have a meaningful life,
but there's no mucking around.
It means responsibility.
It means that the decisions you make are
important.
It means that when you do something
wrong,
it's wrong.
Well,
do you want that.